so now that the Olympics are taking
place in Rio right now we felt we should
try out some of the challenges that a
lot of the Olympians in Brazil are going
to be facing so we've devised couple
challenges and courtesy how we would
compare against the Olympians
today we do the vomit purse relay
apparently an Olympian was vomited on as
a distraction and then Rob distracting
bar yeah
distracting Bart it's like we walk down
the street like that man is really
suspiciously drinking that whole gallon
of milk right now powder robbed me Peter
will vomit on Jake initiating the
robbery by Sam who then pass it on to
Nico who will attempt to pass it on to
rent all the while Jake will be
attempting to chase down his stolen
purse first one to the Container wins
yeah
that first
ah
Pizza with a lovely projectile vomits
Sam takes the bag and manages to hand it
off to Niko Jake closing in behind but
when takes it home with his cat-like
nimbleness and speed did he win it
doesn't really matter
car wheel of X was like I thought it's
like grass trimmings mysteries actually
I was like dude sweet try crumbs on it
I'm scared scared crystallize this is
literally a pile of weed in our street
the armed man pointed the gun at tests
asked for money
then shoved her before stealing the
bikes then taking off so an Australian
Paralympian was robbed which has now
inspired the second event the mugging
challenge two opponents face off one the
mugger tries to get away this much like
in the other one the muggy tres get away
with as much as they can as well for
Consuela the most wins I can't wait to
see the track give me my money item
selected headphones Chinese money and a
nice leather jacket that'll go for a lot
on the street around here we're gonna
turn it face that wall right now her
face that way
I don't think all your stuff man I just
take all your stuff I got a backpack I
got the leather jacket again and I got
the cellphone this time
Bren still kept the money and his
headphones I don't know if I'll be able
to get the backpack again but I'll
certainly try good for all around what
happens if you get caught cheating dude
I don't know maybe we'll be DQ'd Erica
you're down on the ground all right all
right don't want to do this and I don't
I want to do this oh I made out pretty
well that one I think we can ascertain
that the rope to money not effective in
the year 2016
maybe is a good weapon like you're like
strategy for me look you can use it to
catch muggers I can see it in his eyes
and Nick worked really hard this whole
life saving money for years working a
really shitty job at a podunk YouTube
studio and here he is get off the train
you only think give me the money drop
all your values on the ground okay okay
okay okay now there's no one
Oh August and I saw Jake flinch pretty
hard put two packs of money one loan
that's it yeah Nick took gold yes so
apparently a lot of researchers and
scientists have said that the water in
Brazil so toxic that 3 teaspoons of it
is enough to give you a virus a recent
ap report suggests that anyone who
ingests more than 3 tablespoons of the
stuff is going to contract the virus
bottles toy dolls a layer of scum and
last week a corpse spotted in the bay
the w-h-o advising athletes who go into
the water not to swallow it to cover
open wounds and wash immediately after
they get out my kids I wouldn't let them
go enter this waters dude what in it
what oh I totally bled in it oh wow this
is super gnarly now yeah I didn't check
myself I actually know ain't no actually
I did I'd nicked my finger here and
nicked my finger
I really just hate this for babies yet
so 100 oh there's one there's a 100%
chance does it drop my blood in there so
I've got some virus filled water here
where to see if anyone can stomach it
garbage and blood in there Oh God if you
can survive this and not get sick you're
ready for real huh hundred all of it I
see everyone two three out of four one
two and on it a little bit
that dysentery yet brings it to this
oh my god this is awful what does it
taste like it tastes like like sugary
toilet water
Oh
what are you doing whoa it's not gold
Melva beer
oh I hope you guys enjoyed our crappy
Olympics funny thing is so today's the
day after we recorded that and I was
hanging out with Alex Knoll who works
with Brandon he was like yeah bandit was
outside and we caught bandit after she
ate a bunch of the weed off that ground
and so she was acting really weird like
twitchy and the like walking sideways
for the rest of the day and they had to
take her to the vet vet said she was
fine but he's like yeah she has
THC poisoning